tenemos aquí la ecuación balanceada de
la descomposición de dióxido de
nitrógeno en óxido nítrico y oxígeno en
el inciso a nos piden que utilicemos los
datos para mostrar que la descomposición
del dióxido de nitrógeno es una reacción
de segundo orden por acá tenemos estos
datos que nos dicen el tiempo y la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno
ahora para poder demostrar que la
descomposición del dióxido de nitrógeno
es una reacción de segundo orden tenemos
que recordar la ley de la velocidad
integrada que sacamos en el vídeo pasado
lo que encontramos es que 1 entre la
concentración del reactivo al tiempo t
es igual a la constante de velocidad de
la reacción por el tiempo t más 1 sobre
la concentración inicial del reactivo
cierto porque esta es la ley de la
velocidad integrada para
acciones de segundo orden ahora en esta
reacción que es la que nos interesa el
reactivo es dióxido de nitrógeno
entonces la ley de la velocidad
integrada para esta reacción es uno
entre la concentración del dióxido de
nitrógeno al tiempo pues el tiempo que
nos interese esto es igual a la
constante de velocidad de esta reacción
que la denotamos por acá por el tiempo
más 1 entre la concentración inicial del
dióxido de nitrógeno esto tiene la forma
de una línea recta ok si ponemos por
aquí ye igual a m x + b si tomamos el
tiempo y lo grafica mos en el eje de las
equis y luego tomamos 1 entre la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno y
lo grafica mos en el eje de la sed
y en esa gráfica ponemos todos los datos
que tenemos por aquí lo que dijimos en
el vídeo pasado es que si la gráfica de
todos estos datos experimentales en
estos ejes es una línea recta entonces
esta es una reacción de segundo orden
donde además la pendiente de la recta
que obtengamos es igual a la constante
de velocidad de la reacción y la
ordenada al origen es 1 sobre la
concentración inicial de dióxido de
nitrógeno
bueno pero ahora si queremos con estos
datos demostrar que esta reacción es una
reacción de segundo orden todavía nos
falta un paso aunque hay porque queremos
graficar estos datos utilizando estos
ejes sin embargo aquí en el eje de las
veces tenemos uno entre la concentración
del dióxido de nitrógeno mientras que en
estos datos simplemente tenemos la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno
primero que nada lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar uno entre la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno y
eso va a estar en molares al menos uno
pero es muy fácil encontrar estas
cantidades simplemente tenemos que
dividir uno entre cada una de estas que
es lo que vamos a hacer ahorita sacamos
la calculadora y ponemos uno en 3.008
eso es 125 entonces por aquí vamos a
poner 125 y ahora queremos uno entre
punto 0 0 66 volvemos a sacar la
calculadora y tenemos uno entre punto 0
0 6 6
152 que entonces ponemos por aquí 152 y
vamos con este 1 entre punto 0 0 56 es
igual a 179 lo ponemos por aquí 179 y
finalmente uno entre punto 0-0 485 uno
entre punto 00 485 y eso es 206 muy bien
ponemos por aquí 206 y ahora sí ya
estamos listos para graficar esto va a
estar en el eje h y el tiempo va a estar
en el eje x bueno vamos a graficar
nuestros datos en el eje de las equis
tenemos el tiempo y en el eje de las
tenemos uno entre la concentración del
dióxido de nitrógeno y el primer punto
que vamos a graficar
es cuando el tiempo es igual a cero
nunca y aquí tenemos el tiempo igual a
cero y cuando el tiempo es igual a cero
la concentración es 0.00 801 entre la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno
es 125 entonces aquí está el 150 más o
menos por aquí está el 125 y luego
cuando el tiempo es igual a 50 segundos
1 entre la concentración del dióxido de
nitrógeno es 152 entonces nos vamos a 50
segundos
y 152 debe de estar más o menos por aquí
entonces nos quedamos por acá después
cuando el tiempo es igual a 100 segundos
1 entre la concentración del dióxido de
nitrógeno es 179 2
más o menos por acá entonces ponemos un
puntito por aquí y finalmente cuando el
tiempo es 150 segundos 1 entre la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno
es 206 o sea más o menos por aquí que
por acá
veamos si tenemos más o menos una línea
recta como podemos ver estos puntos
están bastante cerca a formar una línea
recta entonces hemos demostrado que es
una reacción de segundo orden claramente
no hice un trabajo perfecto graficando
estos datos pero si podemos observar que
siguen el patrón de una línea recta
entonces ya terminamos con el inciso
y ahora vamos con el inciso b
queremos calcular el valor de la
constante de velocidad de esta reacción
a 300 grados celsius y ya sabemos que la
pendiente de esta recta marker y la
pendiente es igual a la constante de
velocidad de la reacción entonces pues
simplemente tenemos que calcular esta
pendiente y de esa forma encontramos
inmediatamente la constante de velocidad
ahora como le vamos a hacer para
encontrar la pendiente de esta recta
sabemos que la pendiente es igual al
cambio en el eje de las 'íes' entre el
cambio en el eje de las equis entonces
pues podríamos simplemente escoger dos
de estos cuatro puntos por ejemplo éste
este y encontrar el cambio en el eje de
la sie del talle y dividirlo entre el
cambio en el eje de las x delta x y
bueno eso sería una forma muy sencilla
de hacerlo y además es muy fácil
encontrar las unidades porque el cambio
en el eje de las s está en molares al
menos 1 molares a lo menos 1 y el cambio
en el eje de las x está en segundos
entonces por aquí ponemos segundos que
pues esto se puede escribir como uno
entre molares por segundos aunque hay
entonces esta es la unidad de la
constante de velocidad de las reacciones
de segundo orden pero pues esta no es la
única forma de encontrar estas unidades
también podemos usar la ley de la
velocidad de reacción es de segundo
orden que nos dice que la velocidad de
la reacción es igual a la constante de
velocidad por la concentración del
reactivo que en este caso es dióxido de
nitrógeno
y esta concentración elevada al cuadrado
la velocidad de la reacción se mide en
molares sobre segundo y aquí tenemos
igual a la constante de velocidad por la
concentración del reactivo que se miden
molares pero elevado al cuadrado ok
entonces necesitamos más espacio
entonces por aquí tenemos molares sobre
segundo igual a la constante de
velocidad por molares al cuadrado un
molar se cancela con un molar y nos
queda uno sobre segundos igual a la
constante de velocidad por molar o sea
que la constante de velocidad es igual a
1 entre molares por segundos
como podemos observar nos quedó
exactamente lo mismo entonces no importa
como obtengas las unidades de acá
siempre te quedan exactamente las mismas
unidades que vamos para arriba otra vez
ahora sí ahora sí vamos a calcular la
pendiente de la recta que mejor se
ajusta a todos estos datos pero para
obtener la recta que mejor se ajuste a
los cuatro puntos necesitamos utilizar
la información que nos aportan todos
estos cuatro puntos no simplemente la
que nos aportan dos de estos puntos y
para poder integrar toda la información
vamos a utilizar una hoja de cálculo y
para tener la información un poco más a
la mano vamos a movernos para acá
sacamos la hoja de cálculo no queremos
que nos tape los datos y vamos a subir
la columna del tiempo a la hoja de
cálculo ella esta va a ser la columna
del tiempo el eje x
y empezamos con cero luego tenemos un 50
luego un 100
y luego 150 ahora cuando el tiempo es
igual a 0 1 entre la concentración del
dióxido de nitrógeno es 125 125 después
cuando el tiempo es igual a 50 1 entre
la concentración del dióxido de
nitrógeno es 152 152 después tenemos 179
179 y finalmente tenemos 206 206 ahora
ya que tenemos todos nuestros datos en
la hoja de cálculo sacamos una función y
queremos la pendiente de la recta que
mejor se ajuste a todos estos datos
entonces ponemos pendiente podemos
aceptar nos pregunta cuáles son los
conocidos x escogemos todos los datos
que pertenecen al eje x y después
tenemos que señalar cuáles son los datos
del eje y estos son los datos del eje
que son 1 entre la concentración del
dióxido de nitrógeno
y listo aquí nos dice cuál es la
pendiente de la recta que mejor se
ajusta a estos datos marcar y punto 54
bueno así es que la pendiente de esta
recta es 0.50 y 40 pues la pendiente es
la constante de velocidad de la reacción
o sea que acá es igual a 0.54 y listo ya
terminamos porque ya calculamos el valor
de la constante de velocidad de la
reacción que es 0.54 así y por cierto se
me olvidó escribir las unidades pero
como tenemos por aquí es uno sobre
molares por segundo
y ahora si ya terminamos ya encontramos
la constante de velocidad utilizando los
datos experimentales que nos dieron